I feel like the show last episode  finally sets up what we wanted we won  the war we won the games we wanted the  chess match we wanted to outsmart it the  first one was like it's really hard to  squeeze a baby out of your [ __ ] nah  they made that excuse me  this last episode that [ __ ] look hard  bro hard why she had all the nurses in  the room it ain't that hard for come on  bro  maybe for white women  I don't know if that's a good thing  ain't no way Latinas are going through  that every single time that they have a  baby oh yeah after the first one exactly  how many more friends do you need to not  watch this dumb show I just need a  divorce  that's really all I would think well  that's really all I'll take come on now  too many come on now